instead of actually engaging with you
they'll either be unable to actually
comprehend the the moral philosophy or
the math and science by what you're
arguing and then they'll just lie I
think the tribalism nature of it short
circuits their brain just a little bit
like you can't actually go forward when
you have a dog in the fight of who wins
so it's like if if we're okay with the
idea that Obama is prosecuted for war
crimes and you're also you also have to
be okay with the idea that Trump would
be prosecuted for the same thing if he
did indeed do that same thing but if
they have a dog in the fight if they say
no I cannot let Barack Obama or Joe
Biden or whoever uh fall because I
believe so strongly in the leftist cause
I guess it's not really liberal it's
neoliberal at best like you can't allow
new data because you're just not going
to believe that that's actually true you
just think they're trying to get one
over on you because they believe that
your every bit as tribal as they are